[Music]
Hello and welcome. You're watching Yahoo
Finance Live for this special exclusive
coverage of the Daily Journal's annual
meeting of shareholders. I'm Julia Lar
Ro coming to you from Miami, Florida.
I'm now going to send things over to Los
Angeles where we have the Daily
Journal's CEO Jerry Salsman and Charlie
Munger, chairman of the board for some
opening remarks before the shareholder
questioning begins. Charlie, the floor
is yours.
As usual, we'll go through this formal
agenda very rapidly and then we'll stay
here and answer questions for a very
long time. The questions have all been
submitted by actual shareholders of the
G Daily Journal and Yahoo is just
delivering them to us. Ladies and
gentlemen, wherever you are
via Yahoo Financ's
website,
the meeting will come to order. I'm
Charlie Munger, chairman, and to my
right is Jerry Salsman, CEO.
is
what's all this list of directors for?
Just to let the people know who the
directors are. So the directors are
Jerry Salsman, Peter Kaufman, Mary
Conland,
and Gary Wilcox, who's retiring now, and
myself. Ellen Ireland will be inspector
of elections. We will now propose to
make formal to the formal business of
the meeting
on December 18th, 2020.
The
record date there were 1,380,746
shares of common stock of the company
outstanding.
The total number of shares represented
by proxies at this meeting are 995,682
which are more than enough to constitute
a quorum making the meeting duly or
held. The first order of business is to
reelect the the
four directors
and the votes are as follows. Charles
Mer 679481.
Gerald Salsman 660 287. Peter Kaufman
593 336. Mary Conland 651 450 493.
[Applause]
Because we have the proxies, those
directors are now reelected. The second
proposal is to ratify the appointment of
our certified public accountant,
Baker Tilly,
US LLP.
And we
the votes in favor of that are 995
356 and against 120. That's interesting.
You who in the hell is voting against
the the accountants?
[Applause]
But the accountants are duly elected and
we will now proceed to the question
period.
Go ahead.
Thank you Charlie. Uh, our first
question comes from Michael Wong.
Michael Wong asked, "In this year's
annual letter, you mentioned the share
price increase was driven by speculative
frenzy and forced index buying. I would
imagine that applies to the broad
market, too. What are the psychological
implications of this type of market
behavior? What could investors do to
cope better with periodical frenziness?
Well, these things do happen in a market
economy. You get crazy booms. Remember
the dotcom boom when every little
building in Silicon Valley rented at a
huge price and a few months later they
were about a third of them were vacant.
Uh there are these periods in capitalism
and and
I've been around for a long time and my
policy has always been to just ride them
out. And I think that's what
shareholders do. In fact, what
shareholders actually do is a lot of
them crowd in to buying stocks on frenzy
frequently on credit because they see
that they're going up. And of course,
that's a very dangerous way to invest.
I think that
shareholders should be more sensible and
not crowd into stocks and just buy them
just because they're going up and they
like to gamble.
And of course,
Keibling once wrote a famous poem called
the women. And
then the concluding line was
uh
to the effect that you should learn
about women from him instead of do
yourself. But he says, "I know you won't
follow my advice."
Go ahead. Next question.
Thanks, Charlie. Um, our second
question, we have a couple of
shareholders who are asking about this
latest retail frenzy. Um, so we have
Gavin Smith who asks, "What are Mr.
Munger's thoughts on the recent GameStop
short squeeze by social media and the
resulting implications on short selling
in the future?" And another shareholder
named Lee asked, "Dear Mr. Munger,
please share your thoughts on the recent
Wall Street Bets GameStop short squeeze.
It seems to involve a lot of your
standard causes of human misjudgment.
Well, it certainly does. And uh that's
the kind of thing that can happen when
you get a whole lot of people who are
using liquid stock markets to gamble the
way they would on in betting on
resources. And that's what we have going
in the in the uh stock market. And and
the frenzy is fed by people who are
getting
uh commissions and other revenues out of
this new bunch of gamblers. And of
course,
when things get extreme, you have things
like that short squeeze. It's not
generally noticed by the public, but
clearing houses clear all these trades.
And when things get as crazy as they
were in the event you're talking about,
there are threats of clearing house
failure. So it gets very dangerous. And
it's really stupid to have a culture
which uh encourages as much gambling in
stocks by people who have the mindset of
race dog racetrack betters. And of
course it's going to create trouble as
it did. And
I have a very simple idea on this
subject. I think you should try and make
your money in this world by selling pe
other people things that are good for
them. And if you're selling them
gambling services where you rake profits
off the top like many of these new
brokers who specialize in luring the
gamblers in, I think it's a dirty way to
make money. And I think that we're crazy
to allow it.
Next,
our next question.
Our next question.
Our next question comes from Andrew
Wilkinson. He would like to know, "What
do you hope the future of the Daily
Journal Corporation looks like in a
decade?"
decade.
Well, I certainly hope that they succeed
mightily in their software endeavor to
to automate all these courts for the
modern world. And and uh and I
think that could happen, but of course
that's no not a sure thing.
I hope the newspaper survives too. And
that's not a sure thing either.
Dear Mr. Munger and Mr. Salsman, this
question comes from Matthew Peterson, I
should mention. He writes, "The highly
configurable JTI product may help e
Suite integrate deeply into new
jurisdictions as agencies and citizens
become familiar with the courthouse
software. Today, the more the majority
of contractual revenue that can be
identified is from implementations and
licenses. What are the main sources of
ancillary revenue expected once the
products have gone live and how
meaningful will the products like e file
it e pay it cloud hosting services and
others become?
Well, we don't really know where it's
all going. We do know one thing and that
is the courts of the whole world are
going to be taken into the modern age.
And as Jerry just said to me at
breakfast
just after breakfast,
he wouldn't want to invest in a parking
lot by a courthouse for the future
because an awful lot of the court
proceedings are going to go to the
internet. And this is a highly desirable
thing and if you go to a little country
like Estonia, the whole damn company
country is on the internet and it's a
very good idea. So I think you can count
on the fact that that that what we're
doing is going to be a it's in a big
growing field. That's the good news. The
bad news is it's not clear who's going
to win
all the business or how much money is
going to be made.
Generally speaking,
people assume that we're a normal
software company like Microsoft or
something. We are in fact in a more
difficult type of the software business
than Microsoft. We we when you respond
to software by the RFP process, it's a
very difficult demanding
business and it's less profitable and
less sure than what Microsoft does.
But we love it anyway. It It's doing a
big public service.
Go ahead.
All right. Our our next question, uh, we
had a couple questions about, um, JP
Rick Garin. Uh we have Tom Seymour and
Thomas Chang both asking um if you all
would share a few stories about him and
your fondest memory.
Fondest memory.
Well, I always of course I'm he was one
of my closest friend for many decades
and
and he was very good company and a
splendid gentleman and of course we we
accomplished quite a bit working
together.
Rick was part of the group which
consisted of of Warren Buffett, Rick
Garrett, and Charlie Mer that bought
control of blue chip stamps when it was
widely distributed as in an antitrust
settlement. And we were together in that
for a long long time. And and then Rick
and I did the Daily Journal together at
another occasion. And
and Rick was always humorous, always
intelligent. I tell the story on Rick
that
he he took the Navy's IQ test and he got
the one of the highest scores ever
recorded and left early. And that
doesn't happen. That's the reason he
rose so fast in life. He was just so
damn smart. And of course, he was fun to
be with because he was always jumping
out of airplanes and parachutes and
running marathons and so on, doing all
kinds of things I would never consider
doing. And he was a lot of fun. And he
he was a great kid. He loved to kid
people. And and of course, he was very
courageous and generous in helping
everybody around him all his life. He
was an abs. We miss Rick terribly,
but he was 90 years of age. She had a
long and wonderful run.
And and of course,
when you're as old as I am, when these
people go, you there's no replacing
them.
Jerry, can you ever remember Rick down?
He was always upbeat.
Always upbeat. Yes.
and interested and up to speed and
didn't have to take a lot of time to get
background information to make his
comments.
Always on point.
Well, it helps to be
be able to leave the IQ test early with
the highest score.
Our
our next shareholder question is from
Adam Smith from Muny, Indiana. He asks,
"Now that we are cash flow positive,
assuming the software business is
investing organically as much as it can,
what is the philosophical thinking with
respect to capital allocation at the
Daily Journal? Are traditional dividends
and share repurchases the likely
endstake? assuming our software business
grows into a bonafideed company or will
buying and holding securities from time
to time be what the board is comfortable
with? Everyone knows this isn't a small
cap Bergkshire Hathaway. Just trying to
get a feel for what the long-term
capital allocation is.
Well, our the business around here that
has the most promise is our software
business, automating the courts, and
we're going to play that as hard as we
can. And and we hope to do well in it.
And our marketable securities are just a
we prefer owning common stocks to
holding cash in under current
conditions.
and and it's kind of an accident that we
have so much in marketable securities.
We had a couple of questions um around
succession planning. We have one from
Ryan Fusaro from New York City. Uh
Charlie, he writes, "In recent years,
Birkshshire Hathaway has provided much
greater insight into the company's
succession thoughts and has made
available at the annual meeting the
company's leading managers that will
steer Burkshere's future. These actions
have given some shareholders more
visibility uh and comfort on their
investment. Can you provide similar
insight regarding the future at the
Daily Journal? And would you consider
implementing policies like those at
Birkshere so shareholders can get to
know the upandcoming leaders in the
organization?
Well, the people doing the computer
software are doing magnificently well.
the people under Jerry, Mary, Joe and
Danny, and and we hope they'll continue
doing magnificently well, but of course,
it's a very difficult field and there's
a lot of competition and we're a very
small company compared to our main
competitor. And so,
we can't promise we're going to succeed.
All we can promise is we're going to
try.
And so far as I can tell, we're doing
pretty well.
Jerry, don't you think we're doing
pretty well?
I think so, Charlie.
Yeah,
I would go further.
I don't think Jerry's surprised that the
people doing the work, Mary, Joe, and
Danny are are doing well, but I'm
flabbergasted at how well they're doing.
Charlie refers to the course many times.
The JTI software
has been configured for other judicial
and justice agencies including district
attorneys, prosecutors, public
defenders,
probation, etc. So we have one basic
system configured a number of different
ways including workers comp for a large
state in the United States.
What? It's a huge field in which we have
a very interesting tow hold with the
strongest tow holds in Australia and
California.
And but we can't promise what the
outcome will be, but
but we
we're trying pretty hard and we get some
favorable impressions of progress.
The one thing I can promise is that I
won't contri contribute much to it
because I don't understand it.
Our
next shareholder question comes from
Simon Jacobs. He writes, "Many observers
see market behavior that reminds them of
the dot bubble, wild speculation,
endless backs, and IPOs soaring on their
first day of trading. Do you agree that
there is a close parallel to the late
90s and this is therefore quote m this
therefore quote must end badly. must end
badly.
Yes, I think it must end badly, but I
don't know when.
you know, another shareholder, Bill
Roberts asked um about spaxs and he
points out it seems like everyone
including actors, athletes, singers, and
politicians are getting into the
business of promoting their own spa. Why
do you think all these spaxs and the
promoter what what do you think of all
of the spaxs and the promoters pushing
them?
Well, I don't participate at all and I
think the world would be better off
without them. I think this kind of crazy
speculation
and enterprises not even found or picked
out yet is a sign of of
an irritating bubble. It's just that the
investment banking profession will sell
shed as long as shed can be sold.
Richard Lewis from Culver City,
California. He asks, "Charlie, last
February, you spoke about the wretched
excess in the financial system. Given
the developments over the past year,
could you give us an update on your
assessment of wretched excess in the
system? Where does it appear most
egregious?
Well, it's it's most egregious in the
momentum trading by novice investors
lured in by
new types of brokerage operation like
Robin Hood. And I think all of this
activity is regrettable. I think
civilization would do better without it.
You'll remember that when the first big
bubble came, which was the South Sea
bubble in England back in the 1700s,
it created such havoc eventually when it
blew up that England didn't allow hardly
any public trading in securities of any
companies for decades thereafter. It
just created the most unholy mess. So
human greed and the aggression of the
brokerage community creates these
bubbles from time to time and I think
wise people just stay out of them.
Our our next question comes from Achit
Patel. He says, "Charlie, in your past
speeches, you have mentioned the term
functional equivalent of embezzlement to
describe situations where bubbles can
form because both parties involved in a
bubble believe the asset to be worth
more than it truly is. Can US Treasury
bonds be such a case today? and what are
the implications since treasury assets
underpin the value of every other asset.
Thank you for all you do to educate us.
Well, no, I don't think we have a bubble
in Treasury securities. I think they're
a bad investment
when interest rates are this low and I I
never buy any of the daily the Daily
Journal.
But
no, I I don't I don't think Treasury
securities are a big problem. I I do
think that we don't know what these
artificial low interest rates are going
to do or how the economy is going to
work in the future as governments print
all this extra money. And I have the
only opinion I have there is that I
don't think anybody knows what's going
to happen for sure.
Larry Summers has recently been quoted
as being worried that we're have too
much stimulus and I don't know whether
he's right or not.
Jason Subatkkey um he asked previously
you have said quote it takes character
to sit with all that cash and do
nothing. I didn't get to where I am
going after medio but I didn't get to
where I am by going after mediocre
opportunities. End quote. In the past
few years, equity prices have increased
significantly and cash has arguably
become riskier due to central banking
policy. Have you considered amending
this quote or lowering your standards?
Well, I think everybody is willing to
hold stocks at higher price earnings
multiples when interest rates are as low
as they are now.
And so I I don't think it's necessarily
crazy that good companies sell at way
higher multiples than they used to. On
the other hand, it
as you say, I didn't get rich by buying
stocks at high price earnings multiples
in the midst of crazy speculative booms.
And I'm not going to change.
I am more willing to hold stocks at high
multiples than I would be if interest
rates were a lot lower. Everybody is.
Styr Tibville. He asks,
"Do you think value investing is still
relevant in a GDP decreasing world? And
what about passive investing?
Well, that is easy.
Value investing, the way I regard it,
will never go out of style because value
investing, the way I conceive it, is is
always wanting to get more value than
you pay for when you buy a stock. And
and that approach
will never go out of style. Some people
think that value investing is you chase
companies which have a lot of cash and
earn a lousy business or something. But
I don't define that as value investing.
I think all good investing is value
investing. It's just that some people
look for values in strong companies and
some look for values in weak companies.
But but every value investor tries to
get more value than he pays for. What is
interesting is that in wealth
management, a lot of people think that
if they have a hundred stocks, they're
investing more professionally than they
are if they have four or five. I regard
this as insanity.
Absolute insanity. I find it much easier
to find four or five investments where I
have a pretty reasonable chance of being
right that they're way above average. I
think it's much easier to find five than
it is to find a hundred. I think the
people who argue for all this
diversification,
by the way, I call it deworsification
and which I copied from somebody and and
I'm way more comfortable owning two or
three stocks which I think I know
something about and where I think I have
an advantage.
Norman Bergman, he asks,
"Why is Berkshire Hathaway selling
shares of Well Fargo Wells Fargo as
quickly as one can and the Daily Journal
has sold one share? If it's not good
enough for Birkshere, shouldn't we have
the same standards?"
Well, I don't think it's required that
we be actually the same on everything.
We have different tax considerations.
Uh
there's no question about the fact that
Wells Fargo has disappointed long-term
investors like like uh Berkshire because
the old management which is now removed
were not consciously
malevolent or thieving but they had
terrible judgment in having a culture
culture of cross-selling where the
incentives on the poorly paid employees
were too great to to to sell stuff the
customers didn't really need. And when
the evidence came in that the system
wasn't working very well because the
some of the employees were cheating some
of the customers. Well, they came down
hard on the customers instead of
changing the system. That was a big
error in judgment. and and of course
it's regrettable.
So you you can understand why Warren got
disenchanted with with Wells Fargo.
I think I'm a little more lenient. I I
expect
less out of bankers than he does.
Atar Khan from Toronto, Canada. He asks,
"What is the wisdom behind holding bank
stocks compared to other stocks? Are
they more stable?"
Well, I think all stocks can fluctuate
and
and I do think banking run intelligently
is a very good business. But a very wise
man was said on an early occasion, our
trouble with banking is we have more
banks than we have bankers.
the kind of executives who have a
Buffet-like mindset and never get in
trouble are a minority group, not a
majority group. And and so it's it's
hard to run a bank intelligently.
There's a lot of temptation to do dumb
things which will make the earnings next
quarter go up but are bad for the long
term. And some bankers yield to the
temptations. So it's a it's it's
difficult but it's not impossible
investing in bank stock successfully.
Jeffrey Mallaloy asks uh what is the
biggest competitive threat to US banks
like Bank of America and US Bank uh both
equity holdings of the Daily Journal
Corporation over the long term? He
asked, "Is it digital wallets like
PayPal, Square, or Apple Pay? Is it
Bitcoin, decentralized finance, or
something else?"
Well, I don't think I know exactly what
the future of banking is, and I don't
think I know what how the payment system
will evolve. I do think that a
properlyun bank is a great contributor
to civilization and that the central
banks of the work world like controlling
their own banking system and their own
money supplies. So I don't think Bitcoin
is going to end up the medium of
exchange for the world. It's too
volatile to serve well as as a medium of
exchange
and
it's really kind of an artificial
substitute for gold. And since I never
buy any gold, I never buy any Bitcoin
and I recommend that other people follow
my practice.
It Bitcoin reminds me of what Oscar Wild
said about fox hunting. He said it was
the pursuit of the uneatable by the
unspeakable.
Charlie, you actually got a couple of
questions from shareholders um about
Bitcoin. And uh one followup here, Mark
Blakeley from Tulsa, Oklahoma, he asked
if your opinion on cryptocurrencies has
remained the same and would the Daily
Journal consider Bitcoin or any other
cryptocurrency as an asset on the
balance sheet similar to what Tesla
recently did?
No, we will not be following Tesla into
Bitcoin.
All right, we have another shareholder
question. Suzanne Erica from Germany.
She asks about BYD.
BYD is in the Daily Journal stock
portfolio with a very big paper gain.
The stock has gained so much this year
and last year. The stock appreciated
probably way more than intrinsic value.
How do you decide to hold on to a stock
or sell some?
Well, that's a very good question.
BYD stock did nothing for the five
years, first five years we held it and
last year it quintupled.
And what happened was that BYD
is very well positioned for the transfer
of Chinese automobile production from
gasoline fire
um driven cars to electricitydriven
cars. You can't imagine it's in a
wonderful position. And that excited the
people in China which has its share of
of crazy speculators. And so the the
stock went way up since we admire the
company and like its position and we
like its
uh we have a tendency to to to
and we pay huge taxes to a combination
of the federal government and the state
of California when we sell something.
And on balance, we're we're we hold in
to certain of these positions when
normally they when we wouldn't buy a new
position. Practically everybody does
that. One of my smartest friends in
venture capital is constantly getting
huge clumps of stocks at nosebleleed
prices. And what he does is he sells
about half of them always. That way
whatever happens, he feels smart.
I don't follow that practice, but I
don't I don't criticize it either.
Charlie, we have a a similar question
from a shareholder named Lee. No, no
last name provided here, but um this
person writes, "Dear Mr. Munger, do you
believe the valuations for electric car
manufacturers are in bubble territory?
Both Birksher and Leelu own BYYD, a
company you spoke highly of in the past.
BYD sells at nearly 200 PE. This is
cheap compared to Tesla, uh, currently
valued at over,00 times PE and 24 times
sales. I know Birksher is a long-term
owner and rarely sells securities of
highquality companies it owns in its
portfolio simply because it's
overvalued, for example, Coca-Cola in
the past. However, is there a price too
high that the company's future profits
simply cannot justify? Since we are on
the subject of selling potentially
overvalued security, could you provide
your systems for selling securities?
Well, I so rarely hold a company like
BYD that goes to a nosebleleed price
that I don't think I've got a system
yet. And so
I'm just learning as I go along.
Uh I think you can count on the fact
that if we really like the company and
like the management and that is the way
we feel about BYD, we're likely to be a
little too loyal and I I don't think
we'll change on that.
Uh Charlie Matt Mallister has a question
on Costco.
He asks, "Why almost two years ago did
you believe that the only US stock worth
buying that was the only US stock worth
buying at that time? And why did you
feel that Amazon had more to fear from
Costco than Costco had to fear from
Amazon? And if you believe Jeff Bezos is
one of the best businessmen you have
ever known, would you consider investing
early in any of the new projects he will
inev inevitably focus his attention on
now that he will not have to be as
concerned about the dayto-day
responsibilities of Amazon?
Well, no. I'm a great admirer of Jeff
Bezos, whom I consider one of the
smartest businessmen who ever lived, but
I won't be following him. We have our
crotchets and and I I just don't know
enough about it to
want to go into that activity.
And
every investor when you get into these
hard questions, there's a lot of very
intelligent, honorable people who reach
opposite I opposite conclusions.
And Costco, I do think has has one thing
that that Amazon does not. People really
trust Costco to be delivering enormous
values and that is why Costco
present some danger to Amazon because
they've got a better reputation for
providing value than practically anybody
including Amazon.
Uh, Philip Erica from uh, Germany. He
asks, "How do you control your
investments in a world where reasonable
companies with a good image like GE sink
rapidly into the bottomland of the stock
market? How do you recognize a potential
downfall in a company you hold
slashinvest in? Or is it impossible to
realize a deterioration quickly enough
to exit without a loss?
Well, I I never owned a share of General
Electric because I didn't like the
culture and
and I was not surprised when it blew up.
I do think the present CEO is an
extraordinarily able man and the
directors made a very wise choice when
they put him in charge and I think the
directors of GE have a deserve a lot of
credit for for u making Larry Culp the
CEO. If anybody can fix it, he can.
We have another question. Peter Furlin
from Toronto. Mr. Munger, you famously
run investments through your mental
checklist. Is there anything that you
wish you had added to your checklist
sooner?
Well, I'm constantly making mistakes
where I can in retrospect
realize that I should have decided
differently. And I think that that is
inevitable because it's difficult to be
a good investor.
And
I'm pretty easy on myself these days.
I I'm satisfied with the way things have
worked out and I'm not nashing my teeth
that other people are doing better. And
I think that the methods that I've used,
including the checklists, are the
correct methods. And I'm grateful that I
found them as early as I did and that
the methods have worked as well as they
have. And I recommend that other people
follow my example. It reminds me of
the key phrase in Bunan's Pilgrim's
Progress. He says, "My sword I leave to
him who can wear it."
I'm afraid that's the way we all have to
leave our swords.
Charlie Rhett Madison. He asks, "Uh, you
and Warren have been adept at quickly
sizing people up, particularly business
leaders and potential business partners.
What do you look for in a leader? And do
you and Warren have any tricks or
shortcuts to size people up quickly and
accurately?
Well,
of course, if a person is a chronic
drunk, we avoid him.
Everybody has shortcuts to screen out
certain hazards. And we probably have
more of those shortcuts than others.
and
and uh and they've served us well over
the years
I we one of the great advantages of the
way Bergkshire operates is that we
associate with a lot of marvelous people
and if you stop to think about it that
is also true at the Daily Journal what
little newspaper company
has come through the crisis of that's
destroying all the newsp papers better
than the little Daily Journal.
And we've had marvelous people here who
helped us do it through very difficult
times. And one of them is Jerry Salsman.
And and Jerry and I have been together
how many years, Jerry?
Early 70s.
Early 70s. And
it's rather interesting. I recognized
early that Jerry could run anything he
wanted to run. And when the old CEO of
the Daily Journal died,
uh Jerry was man was the he was managing
the business affairs of the Munger Tolls
law firm and but he'd wor previously
worked for Rick Garren and me in running
a little mutual fund that we bought
control of. And he'd made a very
favorable impression and I said to Rick,
"We're going to make Jerry the head of
the Daily Journal." and he he gasped and
said, "But he's never had anything to do
with newspapers or anything else." I
said, "It won't matter. He'll be able to
do it." And we immediately ascended and
we put Jerry in and he's made every
decision
wonderfully ever since.
That's our system.
Somebody Tom I M I M I M I M I M I M I M
I M I M I M Ivy used to say his system
of management was delegate delegation
just short of total abdication and
that's the way we handled Jerry
Charlie uh Caroline Smolinski uh would
like to know which do you think is
crazier Bitcoin at 50,000 or Tesla's
fully diluted enterprise value of 1
trillion. What do you make of these two
pricings?
Well, I have the
same difficulty that Samuel Johnson once
had when he got a similar question and
he said, "I can't decide the order of
presidency between a flea and a louse."
And I feel the same way about those
choices. I don't know which is worse.
Um, Richard Saunders would like to know,
should there be a tax on buying stock
now that Robin Hood trades are free?
Well,
Robin said Robin Hood trades are not
free. When you pay for order flow,
you're you're probably charging your
customers more and pretending to be
free. It's a very dishonorable,
low-grade way to talk. And and nobody
should believe that Robin Hood's trades
are free.
Um, we have a question from Andrew Peak
in Weston, Connecticut. Mr. Munger. As a
student of Chinese history, my question
concerns China. In 1860,
GDP per capita in China was 600. In
1978,
uh the year Deng Xiaoping took over it
was 300. Today, it hovers around 9,500.
Never before in the history of mankind
have we seen such a rapid eradication of
poverty pulling approximately 800
million people out of destitution. You
are on record as a zealous fan of the
Chinese work ethic and confusion values
system. As we can see from the
deteriorating US relationship with
China, the western world does not
understand China. What can we do to
increase knowledge, understanding, and
appreciation of the Chinese
civilization?
Well, it's natural for people to think
their own civilization and their own
nation is better than everybody else,
but everybody can't be better than
everybody else.
You're right that the China's economic
record among the big nations is the best
that ever existed in the history of the
world. And that's very interesting. A
lot of people assume that
since
England led the industrial revolution
and always
and had free speech early
that uh that free speech is required to
have a booming economy as prescribed by
Adam Smith. But the Chinese have proved
you don't need free speech to have a
wonderful economy. They just copied Adam
Smith and left out the free speech and
it worked fine for them. As a matter of
fact, it's not clear to me that China
would have done better if they'd copied
every aspect of English civilization. I
think they would have come out worse
because
their position was so dire and the
poverty was so extreme, they needed very
extreme methods, totalitarian methods if
you will, to get out of the fix they
they were in. So I think what China has
done was probably right for China and
that we shouldn't be so pompous as to be
telling the Chinese they ought to behave
like us because they like our because we
like ourselves and our system. It
entirely possible that our system is
right for us and their system is right
for them.
Gavin Smith from Berkshire, England. He
asked, "Mr. Mer is a champion of Chinese
stocks. How concerned is he about
Chinese government interference as seen
recently with Ant Financial, Alibaba,
and Mr. Jack Ma? What, for example, is
to stop the Chinese government from
simply deciding one day to nationalize
BYD?
Well, I consider that very unlikely
and I think Jack Ma was very arrogant to
be telling the Chinese government how
dumb they were and how stupid their
policies were and so forth. Considering
their system, that is not what he should
have been doing. And and
no, I don't I don't I don't think that
I I think the Chinese have behaved very
very shrewdly in managing their economy
and they've gotten better results than
we have in managing our economy and and
I think that that will probably
continue. And sure, we all love the kind
of civilization we have. I'm not saying
I want to live in in in China and I I
prefer the United States, but I do
admire what the Chinese have done. How
can you not do it? Nobody else has ever
taken a big country
out of poverty so fast and so long. And
what I see in China now just staggers
staggers me. There are factories in
China that are just absolutely full of
robots and are working beautifully.
They're no longer using peasant girls to
beat the brains out of our little shoe
companies in America. They are joining
the modern world very rapidly and and
they're getting very skillful at at at
operating.
Okay. Uh we have a question from James
Lee from Lacya, California. He writes,
"It seems likely that the current Fed
policy of keeping interest rates near
zero will only exacerbate the income
disparity in this country by benefiting
those who own the financial assets. What
do you think we can do to help those who
are currently falling behind as a result
of this pandemic?"
Well, it's hard to know what exact
macroeconomic policy is correct because
no one knows for sure just how much
government intervention is wise and and
at what point the government should stop
intervening.
And
I don't think we have any great gift at
at making macroeconomic predictions
uh
about how the money and I think that
I think that to some extent
the complaint about
the rich getting richer during the as a
result of the COVID panic. Uh I think
that's a misplaced concern.
Nobody was trying to make the rich
richer.
We were trying to save the whole economy
under terrible conditions. And I think
by and large we made the the most
practical decisions that were available
to us. And the we we made the the rich
richer not as a deliberate choice but
because as an it was an accidental
byproduct of trying to save the whole
civilization. And it was probably wise
that we acted exactly as we did. And it
wasn't some malevolence of the rich that
caused it. It was an accident. And the
next time around, why the poor will get
richer faster than the rich. That thing
circul it that that who gets rich faster
by class is going to vary over time. And
I don't think anybody should be too
concerned by it. As a matter of fact,
what happens is that
to have an to get to make a nation rich,
you need a free market system.
And if you have a free market system
that's trying to get rich in the way
recommended by Adam Smith, what happens
is that the
it's a very irritating system because
the poverty that causes so much misery
is also causing the growth that makes
everybody get out of poverty. In other
words, to some extent, it's a
self-correcting system. And it's very
that makes the whole thing very awkward.
And it's a shame that the economics
textbooks don't emphasize how much a
growing economy needs poverty in order
to get out of poverty. And if you try
and reduce the poverty too much, it's
counterproductive.
And these are very difficult questions.
And most people assume that it's simple.
And if if we could make the world richer
by just raising the minimum wage to
$100,000 a second or something, of
course we would do it, but but we can't.
Uh Gavin Smith would like to know um
Mr. Munger recently raised the alarm
about at the level of money printing
taking place. uh what are his thoughts
on modern monetary theory? monetary
theory. Well, modern ramon monetary
theory means the people are less worried
about
an inflationary disaster like wear
Germany from government printing of
money and spending it and that's
monetary money mon now
so far the evidence would be that maybe
the monetary modern monetary theory is
right put me down as skeptical
I don't know the answer.
We do have
Okay. Um but going back to the Fed, um
William Roberts asks, uh the the Federal
Reserve appears to be supporting asset
prices. Do you think this is a
worthwhile worthwhile policy objective
given the effect it has on creating uh
financial excesses and in income
inequality? Uh, what do you think the
longterm consequences will be?
Well, I don't know how well the economy
is going to work in the future.
And
I don't think that
that we or the Daily Journal is getting
ahead because we've got some wonderful
macroeconomic insight.
And
and I do think that
I'm way less afraid of inequality
than
most people who are bleeding about it.
I think that inequality
is absolutely an inevitable consequence
of having the the policies that that
that make a nation grow richer and
richer and elevate the poor. So I don't
mind a little inequality. And what I
notice is that that the rich families
generally lose their power and wealth
and pretty fast. And so I don't worry
that the country is being ruined by a
few people who are getting ahead a
little faster than the rest of us.
I think the Chinese were very smart.
Imagine a bunch of Chinese communists
turning a whole lot of Chinese into
billionaires in a big hurry. And and
what do the Chinese communists do with
with respect to death taxes? The death
tax in China is zero. That's what the
communists are doing. I think they're
probably right. By the way,
we have a question from Simon Jacobs. Uh
he writes, "Many believe that inequality
accelerated by this pandemic has reached
alarming levels that demands drastic
solutions such as a wealth tax. Do you
agree with the premise? And if so, how
would you dress address inequality?
Well, I think any rich nation
ought to have a social safety net that
expands a little with its wealth.
And that's what we've been doing through
my whole lifetime. And I applaud the
result. And I think the result would
have been worse if either party had been
in control all by itself for the whole
period. In other words, I think the
system of checks and balances and
elections that our founders gave us
actually gave us a pretty much the right
policies during my lifetime
and I hope that that will continue in
the future. But I do think politics is
getting
more full of hatred and irrationality
than it used to be in America. And I
don't think that's good.
Alan Smolinski asks, "Charlie, many
major businesses and high netw worth
individuals have been leaving
California.
Can you speak to the causes, the trend,
and make some predictions?
Yes, I think that is
rising as we sit here. I just see more
and more of the rich people leaving. And
of course, I think it's vastly stupid
for any state to be user friendly to the
rich people. They do way more good than
harm.
And and they lose their money fast
enough you don't need to worry about
them. And so
I I I think the Paul's
Washington state is actually considering
a wealth tax at the state level. I think
that would be insanity.
I predict that if they do that, a lot of
people will leave Washington.
Brian Chin from Los Angeles asks, "With
all the work from home with Zoom and
other technology, what do you think the
future of commercial real estate looks
like?"
Well, real estate has always been a
difficult field
and some types of real estate in recent
years has been particularly difficult.
I think office buildings are now in some
trouble and of course commercial real
estate rented to stores has been in a
lot of trouble for a long time.
Uh, apartments have come through better,
but but
I I don't think
I don't think I've got a lot to
contribute to it. I I own some apartment
houses, so I I I like that that
investment provided you've got a perfect
management, which is hard to get.
Uh we have a a healthc care related
question from Abel Techlu. He asks, "I
was wondering if you could share some
thoughts on Haven, uh particularly why
it was ultimately closed and what were
the lessons learned?"
I don't know anything about Haven.
Yeah. Give Give me a new question.
Sounds good. Um,
so
here we go. I I have a section that
might be of interest to you. Uh, we have
David uh Thompson and he says, "You've
said several times that the best way to
learn about business is to study uh the
multi-deade financial results of great
companies. You've even said business
schools that don't adopt this method are
doing their students a disservice. Would
you mind elaborating on how a professor
or individual should go about building a
curriculum around this approach? What,
for example, would you recommend as
course materials?
Well, here's what I meant.
And by the way, the Harvard Business
School when it started out way early,
they they started out with a history of
business. They take you through the
building of the canals and the building
of the railroads and so on and so on.
and you saw the eb and flow of industry
and the creative destruction of the
economic changes and so on so and it was
a background which helped everybody and
of course what I'm saying is that if I
were teaching business I would start the
way Harvard Business School did a long
time ago. I think they stopped because
if you taught that course you'd be
stealing the best cases from the
individual professors of marketing and
so on and so on and so on. And I I just
think it was academically inconvenient
for them. But of course, you should
start out by studying the history of
capitalism and how it worked and why
before you start studying business.
And they don't do that very well.
I'm talking about the business schools.
If you stop to think about it,
business success long term is a lot like
biology.
And in biology, what happens is the
individuals all die and eventually so do
all the species. And capitalism is
almost as brutal as that. Think of
what's died in my lifetime.
Just think of the things that were once
prosperous that are now in failure or
gone.
Who ever dreamed when I was young that
Kodak and General Motors would go
bankrupt?
You know, it's just it's incredible
what's happened in terms of the
destruction.
And of course, that history is useful to
know.
Next,
uh Charles H from Charles H from New
York. Uh he actually quotes a speech
that you gave a commencement address you
gave in 2007 at USC Law School. I'll
paraphrase here. you wrote or you said
so if a civilization can progress only
when it invents the method of invention
you can only progress when you learn the
method of learning I was very lucky I
came to law school having learned the
method of learning and nothing has
served me better in my long life than
continuous learning Charles H would like
to know what's Charlie's method of
learning
Well, I think I had the right
temperament and when people gave me a
good idea and I could see it was a good
idea, I quickly mastered it and started
using it and just used it for the rest
of my life. And you'd say that everybody
does that in their education, but I
don't think everybody does. It's such a
simple idea.
And of course, without the method of
learning, you're like a one-legged man
in an asskicking contest. It's just not
going to work very well. Take Jerry. You
think the Daily Journal would have
hundreds of millions of marketable
securities now if Jerry didn't know how
to learn something new? He didn't know
one damn thing about the Daily Journal.
We made him head of it. But he knew how
to learn what he didn't know. Of course,
that's a useful thing. And by the way, I
think it's hard to teach. I think it's
to some extent you either have it or you
don't.
Jerry Chang would like to know
and Jerry Chang would like to know uh
why are some people incapable of
learning new ideas and behaviors?
Well, it's partly culture, but I a lot
of it's just born in it's a quirk.
Some people have a
a natural
trend toward good judgment and other
people do just make their life is just a
series of mistakes over and over again.
Uh Lee would like to know Charlie, dear
Mr. Munger, you have revised your famous
talk on the standard causes of human
misjudgment with considerable new
material back in 2005.
Now 16 years have passed. Is there any
new material?
No, I would say that that of course
there's some new material in in in
misjudgment, but but by and large most
of the knowledge has been available for
a long time.
What prevents the wide use of helpful
psychological insight
is the fact that it's
is the psychology gets really useful
when you integrate it with all other
knowledge.
And the reason, but they don't teach
that in the psychology department
because the academic system rewards
little experiments that develop more
insight into psychological tendencies
instead of synthesizing what's already
been discovered with the rest of
knowledge. The psychology professors
don't know all that much about the rest
of knowledge and they have no incentive
to master it. And if you don't have
master the rest of knowledge, you can't
synthesize it with psychology.
So that's a it's a that's an interesting
example of of self-learning.
When I saw that psychology was necessary
and I didn't have it,
I didn't just learn the little
tendencies and well enough to get A's in
psychology. I learned those tendencies
well enough to synthesize some of the
rest of knowledge. and that's the right
way to do it. But show me a psychology
department that knows how to do that.
It's it's one of the most ignorant
professions in the world.
Uh Robert McKenzie asks, "Uh Charlie,
you are known as an advocate for
learning from one's mistakes. What did
you learn from the Barry Dutton's
bookstore building in Brentwood?" uh
that deal and how would you apply that
new knowledge or experience in the
future?
Well, I think I've learned to avoid
zoning work. When I was young, I
reszoneed some properties very
successfully and I was like Rip Van
Winkle when I tried to come back to it.
I found that the world had changed and I
don't think you'll find me engaged in
any massive resonings in the future.
Okay. Um, Vic Aurora asks, uh, what
advice would you give to someone who is
trying to stay within their circle of
competence but finding that the pace of
technical technological innovation is
rapidly reducing that circle?
Well, if
of course if they bring in a brand new
technology you don't understand at all,
you're at something of a disadvantage.
And my advice would be if you're if you
have a fixable disadvantage, remove it.
And if it's unfixable,
learn to live without it. What else can
you do?
You fix what can be fixed and what can't
be fixed you endure.
Frank Wong from Houston,
you are one of the oldest and greatest
thinkers of our time. Any tips for
someone who wants to work on and improve
their ability to hold two opposing views
at the same time? any tips on how to
generate insight in these types of
situations?
Well, I do have a tip at at times in my
life. I've put myself to a standard that
I think has helped me. I think I'm not
really equipped to comment on this
subject until I can state the arguments
against my conclusion better than the
people on the other side.
If you do that all the time, if you're
looking for disisconfirming evidence and
and putting yourself on a grills to make
that is that that's a a good way to help
remove
ignorance.
What happens is that every human being
tends to believe way more than he should
in what he's worked hard to find out or
what he's announced publicly. that he
already believes. In other words, why we
while we shout our knowledge out, we're
really pounding it in without we're not
enlarging it. And and I was always aware
of that. And so I've
accepted these damned annual meetings.
I've I'm pretty quiet.
Uh Ron L has a question about Jean Abeg.
Uh, Gene Abeck seems like he was one of
the best bankers of the last century,
achieving both a extremely low loan loss
rates and earning around 2% on assets
over a long time period. I think the
bankers of today could learn a lot from
Gan, but little is known of him.
question. How did Gan achieve incredibly
low loan losses over the long term while
so many other bankers have failed
miserably?
Well, that is an easy one. He was a very
smart man. He lived in a particular
town. He knew everybody and everything.
He had excellent judgment. He cared
terribly about not not making bad loans
or incurring dumb expenses.
So he was just a perfect banker if you
wanted never to have any trouble. And of
course it really helped to know
everybody in town. If I had stayed in
Omaha where I was raised and gone into
the banking business, I would have been
a hell of a good banker because even as
a boy, I knew a lot about who was sound
and who wasn't sound in Omaha. And
that's the way Jean was in his
community. Furthermore, he'd gone
through the Great Depression. He'd been
a receiver for a bank. Well, of course
that made him very lerary of dumb loans
and and and of course he hated costs. He
was a just a very old-fashioned sound
thinker. And of course that will still
work,
but it's it's hard for anybody else to
he really knew everything you had to to
avoid credit losses and small town in
Illinois.
We have a question uh from Stephen Chen.
Charlie, you have been a longtime
admirer of Singapore and Lie Kuan Yu.
You once said that study the life and
work of Lie Kuan Yu. You are going to be
flabbergasted. I would be curious to
know how did you start your interest
about Singapore and Lie Kuwanu and have
you met Lee Kuanu in person in person
and if there is one thing the world
could learn from Singapore now what
would that be?
Well, Lee Kuanu
had the best record as a nation builder
if you were willing to count small
nations in the group. He had the
probably the best re record that ever
existed in the history of the world. He
took over a malarial swamp with no army,
no nothing. And and pretty soon he
turned that into this gloriously
prosperous place. And and his method for
doing it was so simple. You know the
mantra he said over and over again was
very simple. He said, "Figure out what
works and do it." Now, it sounds like
anybody would know that made sense, but
you know, most people don't do that.
They don't work that hard at figuring
out what works and what doesn't, and
they don't just keep everlastingly at it
the way he did. And
again, he was a very smart man and
and and
he he had a lot of good ideas and he he
he absolutely
took over a malarial swamp and turned it
into modern Singapore in his own
lifetime.
It was absolutely incredible. And he did
not have he it was a one party system,
but he he could always be removed by the
electorate. He was not a dictator
and
he was just so good. He was death on
corruption which was a very good idea.
And there's hardly anything he touched
he didn't improve.
When I look at modern Singapore health
system,
it costs 20% of what the American system
costs. And of course, it works way
better than our medical system. And
that's entirely due to the practical
talent of Lie Kuan Yu. Just time after
time, he would choose the right system.
And
in Singapore, you get a savings account
the day you're born. And if you don't
spend the money, you get to you you and
your heirs get to spend it eventually.
In other words, it is your money. So
that to some extent everybody buying
medical service in Singapore is paying
for it himself. And of course people
behave more sensibly when they're
spending their own money. He just time
after time he would do something like
that that recognized reality and worked
way better than what other people were
doing. And there aren't that many people
like Lee Kuanu that have ever lived. So
of course I admire him. I have a bust of
Lee Quanu in my house. I admire him that
much.
Charlie Ed Collins um he would like to
know what is the biggest lie currently
being perpetuated by the investment
complex?
Well, confess confus uh
commissionf free trading is a is a very
good candidate for that if you're want
to emphasize disgusting lies.
Commission free trading is not free.
Michael or or Shaggy would like to know,
do you think it's best to invest in the
common stocks of businesses early
um or while they are while they are more
nent and the industry is smaller or wait
until they are and wait until they are
the clear winner of a more mature
industry?
Well, I think Warren and I are better at
at buying mature industries than we are
at backing startups like Sequoia.
The best
venture capital operation probably in
the whole world is Sequoas and they are
very good at this early stage
investing and I would hate to compete
with Sequoia in their field. I think
they'd run rings around me.
So I think for some folks early stage
investing is best and for other folks uh
what I've done in my life is best.
Uh Boon asks uh Charlie last year almost
every ecommerce internet and internet
adjacent stock was up 100 plus%.
You've said recently that Sequoia is the
greatest investment firm ever. Do you
think the digital economy has reached a
tipping point such that quote this time
is different? End quote and that
conventional valuation measures for
these types of companies are dead or
does this environment remind you of
1999?
How do you reconcile the idea of paying
50 or 60 times revenue for a growing but
unprofitable business with the more
traditional value investing concept of a
margin of safety?
Well, generally speaking, I don't try
and compete with Sequoia. You can argue
that I got close to Sequoia when with
Leelu we bought into BYD. that was not a
startup, but it was so small and thinly
traded that we were buying into a
venture capital type investment, but in
the public market. But with that one
exception, I've stayed out of Sequoia's
business because they're so much better
at it than I would be, and I don't know
how to do it the way they do it.
Um, Michael Asel asks, Of the various
types of moes and competitive
advantages,
which types do you think will be most
important in the years ahead? And what
combinations of competitive advantages
can you imagine will create any new
types of modes?
Well, that's too hard and general a
question for me. The uh
the one thing I will say is that a lot
of the moes that looked impassible,
people found a way to just look think of
all the monopoly newspapers that used to
be in effect part of the government of
the United States and they're all dying.
Every damn one of them almost
a lot of the old moes are are going
away. And of course, people are creating
new moes all the time. That's the nature
of capitalism. It's like evolution in
biology.
New species are created and old species
are dying.
And of course, it's hard to negotiate in
such a field.
And but there's no rule that life has to
be easy on the mental side. Of course,
it's going to be difficult.
Um, Vishall Patel in Toronto.
Vichel Patel in Toronto says uh I
enjoyed your Caltech interview and
wanted you to elaborate and provide more
insights on your point of great
investors and great chess players. How
are they similar or different? And
Vashall also wants to know Charlie if
you have seen the television show
Queen's Gambit on Netflix.
Well, I have seen an episode or two of
the Queen's Gambit, and what I think is
interesting about chess is to some
extent,
you can't learn it unless you have a
certain natural gift. And even if you
have a natural gift, you can't be good
at it unless you start playing at a very
young age and get huge experience. So
it's a very interesting
competitive field and I think that great
investment I think people have the
theory that any intelligent hardworking
person can get to be a great investor.
I think any intelligent person can get
to be pretty good as an investor and
avoid certain obvious traps. But I think
that that
I don't think everybody can be a great
investor or a great chess player. If you
I knew a man once, Henry Singleton, who
was not a chess champion, but he could
play chess blindfolded at just below the
grandmaster level. But Henry was a
genius. And there aren't many people
that can do that. And if you can't do
that, you're not going to win the chess
championship of the world. You're and
you're not going to do as well in
business as Henry Singleton did. I think
some of these things
are very difficult. And I think by and
large it's a mistake to hire in
investment management to hire armies of
people to make conclusions.
Better off to concentrate your decision
power in one person. the way the Leelu
partnership does and and choose the
right person.
I I don't think
I don't think it's easy for ordinary
people to become great investors.
Um we have another question um from
Ankit Patel in Certino California. Hi
Charlie, you identified the opportunity
in electrification and invested in BYD.
How do you think about the hydrogen
opportunity for transportation? And how
does it compare to the electric
opportunity? Specifically, thinking
about trucks versus cars. Will we have
less gas stations or truck stops in the
future?
Well, I hope we don't have less truck
stops because Ber Hathaway is deeply
involved in truck stops and but uh of
course I think there will be more
automation and in in uh transportation
of all kinds in the future.
I don't think I've got any great insight
about hydrogen.
I do think it
having a whole system to sell hydrogen
to is is difficult. On the other hand,
the electric the buses in Los Angeles
work on natural gas.
All the buses and it saved Los Angeles a
fortune because gas is so much cheaper
than gasoline.
And so I I've seen a whole bus system
shift to from gasoline or diesel to to a
gas. And so it obvious obviously isn't
impossible,
but you'd have to create a whole new
system of of supply for it. And of
course, I remember
I I don't even know how much more
difficult how much more dangerous it
would be to deal with hydrogen it is to
deal with gasoline, which is also a
dangerous substance.
No, you're you've reached my you've
reached the limit of my circle of
competence. I can't help you.
Got it. Uh we have a couple of uh Daily
Journal related questions from
shareholders. Uh from Miles Marino, he
wants to know, "What would management do
with a sudden windfall of profits? How
would they think about current
opportunities with low rates and low
inflation?"
Well, it's not easy to handle
accumulated money in the current
environment when the stocks are so high
and and many real estate is parcels of
real estate of certain kinds is also
very inflated. So, it's it's very
difficult and all I can say is we'll do
the best we can.
But I don't when it gets difficult I
think
I don't think there's any automatic fix
for difficulty. I think when difficulty
comes, I I expect to have my share.
Norman Bergman uh would like to know,
uh, does management, in your opinion,
have a moral responsibility
to have their shares trade as close to
fair value as possible?
Well, I don't think you can make that a
moral responsibility because if you do
that, I'm a moral leper
because the Daily Journal stock sells at
way above the price I would pay if I
were buying a new stock.
So,
no, I don't think it's the
responsibility of management to assure
where the stock sells.
I think the a management should tell it
like it is at all times and
and not be a big promoter of its own
stock. But
Tom Seymour um he has a question. In
1999, the year the Daily Journal bought
Sustain, the traditional business
employed 355
full-time employees and 61 part-time
employees. In 2010, that was down to 165
full-time employees and 15 part-time
employees. This year's annual report
suggests that the traditional business
has 97 full-time employees. Has the
quality of the publications suffered as
the employment levels have decreased? Or
has the digital revolution caused
enormous productivity improvements in
those businesses?
Well, of course, the the place is
downsized. It had to because the the
traditional business, newspaper business
is shrinking. And of course, Jerry being
a sound thinker
shr, you know, did the very unpleasant
work of of shrinking it appropriately
and without bothering me or Rick. Uh,
showing how wise we were to put him
there in the first place. Uh,
has the quality gone down? Well, I don't
think the quality in publishing public
notice advertising has gone down.
And but I I I hardly think the editorial
quality could go way up while the
employees were going down. My guess is
we we we have suffered some in editorial
quality. Jerry, do you have a comment on
that?
There are a number of factors
that come into play here and you
mentioned technology that is very very
important. Many of our systems are
in the cloud. All except for the uh
legal advertising system which we had to
build because nobody else has the volume
that we have.
Our editorial system, our advertising
system, all in the cloud. Accounting is
also in the cloud.
And the disruption
from the decline in newspapers has has
had a significant impact.
Classified advertising is down
significantly.
In display advertising, for example,
we now utilize a very friendly company
that worked with us for 25 years and now
they are helping us sell advertising.
Also
fortunately before the pandemic we got
out of the uh conference type events and
uh we were not subjected to the the
problems of no conferences nobody to
attend
and uh when you look at what's happened
in California the price of real estate
and rentals we've
reduced the number of offices we have
both for journal technology and for the
daily journal. Very difficult to hire
reporters in the San Francisco area with
all the demands coming from u the
internet companies wanting to have
editorial product. All those factors
come into play. And also if you go back
a little further, we eliminated
California Lawyer magazine and we had at
one time an office in Seattle and one in
Denver and about the same time we bought
an office in a newspaper in Phoenix. And
that worked out extremely well. that
ones in in uh Seattle and Denver
difficult to break into the legal
advertising system which supports so
many newspapers not only in California
but elsewhere
it's very hard shrinking business
and Jerry has done it magnificently well
this and it was it was totally required
Charlie, our our next question comes
from Mark Blakeley.
Do you believe the market is going
through a long a long-term value slump
similar to 1999, or do you believe
technology has caused a permanent change
in how companies should be valued?
Well, I don't know how permanent it's
going to be, but it certainly caused a
change. And
of course it's hard to know what the
future holds when in a complex system
where where you can't predict a lot of
things and
and
generally what people do is they have
financial reserves so they have some
options if trouble comes and they adapt
the way Jerry has to required
downsizings or required upsizings.
One of the interesting things about the
Daily Journal is that we made all that
money in the foreclosure boom. So, we
were like an undertaker who suddenly got
prosperous in a plague year. And it's a
funny way to make money. And and that
happened because Jerry and I bought
these little flea bitten newspapers all
over the state.
for just as a precaution to make sure we
had we could serve public notice
advertising wherever it arose in the
state and
stop center.
Yes. And and that turned out to be a
wonderful idea and that's one of the
reasons we made all this money. So the
shareholders have been lucky to have
somebody like Jerry here who could learn
what he didn't know and and and fix it.
Charlie Chris Demetra, he asks, "You've
spent much of your life contributing
your wisdom to schools and hospitals.
How would you advise these institutions
to manage their endowments over the
coming decades?"
Well,
the one charitable institution where I
have had some influence for a very long
time
has a whole bunch of hot shot financers
in every branch of wealth management
there is on the board.
And that institution has two assets in
its
endowment accounts.
One is a big interest in Leelu's
China fund, which is a limited
partnership, and the other is a Vanguard
index fund. And as a result of holding
those two positions, we have way lower
costs than anybody else, and we make
more money than practically everybody
else. So you now know what I do in
charitable institutions.
By the way, that's not the normal
outcome in America.
The wealth management industry has a
crisis on its hands.
They really need the world to stay the
way it is.
and that isn't necessarily right for its
customers.
Our next question comes from Randy
Jeffs.
It is estimated that the Gates
Foundation has saved well over a 100
million lives. Buffett's donations to
the foundation has obviously helped to
save many millions.
Are Birksher's managers aware that
through their efforts to create business
success at Birkshere that they have been
involved in saving millions of lives?
Millions of lives.
Well, I'm sure some are, but but by and
large that's not what
Warren is known for.
He doesn't mind at all not getting
credit for his charitable donations.
We have a a question uh from Bergen
Norway. This trumps this comes from
Canute uh Martin Carlson.
He would like to know is the oil and gas
industry the new newspapers?
I don't think so. I think the oil and
gas industry will be here for a long
long time. As a matter of fact, it'll be
here for a long long time if we stop
using as much Asia much uh hydrocarbons
in in transportation.
the hydrocarbons are also needed as
chemical feed stocks
and
and I I don't think that hydrocarbons
are going I'm not saying that oil and
gas is going to be a wonderful business
but I don't think it's going away and I
I I don't I don't think it's like the
newspaper business.
Um we have a couple more uh um energy
related questions. Uh, one from Simon
Jacobs. Actually, this is environmental.
Uh, do you believe global warming is an
existential threat to humankind? And if
so, how do you think society should
address it? Especially because poor
countries require much more cheap en
energy to reduce poverty.
Well, of course, it's very hard to fix
the global warming problem when the poor
countries need to burn coal to stay
alive and so on. And
so, it's it's it's a serious problem.
And on the other hand, we have a fair
amount of time to do it. And a rich
civilization can afford to do it if we
absolutely have to. If the seas were to
rise 60 feet, which could happen in
another hundred years or so, uh 60 feet,
we'd have to build enormous
uh
barriers to sea entry. Florida would
have a
really serious problem. Other hand, it
could be handled. Bill Gates has written
a book on this subject recently which he
concludes that would be expensive but it
could be handled and his conclusion is
that mankind should just step up to it
and do it. And I don't want to quarrel I
kind of admire the way Bill takes on
these very hard problems. I tend to
avoid the ones which I'm not good at and
and I'm not good at a lot of different
problems.
Uh Charlie, probably the most popular
question here.
It's probably too many shareholders, but
they would like to know uh the books
that you're currently reading and books
that you recommend.
I think I'll skip that one. Go on.
Sounds good. Okay. Um Okay. We have one
from Christopher Sai.
He he writes, "Bin Franklin said, "Were
it offered to my choice, I would have no
objection to a repetition of the same
life from its beginning, only asking the
advantages authors have in second
edition to correct some faults of the
first. If you were offered a fresh start
today, what would you do differently in
life and in investing?
Well,
any Ben Franklin was one of the wisest
men who ever lived and yet he made a lot
of mistakes in the course of living his
life. And of course, if he had a chance
to do it over again, he would avoid
those mistakes. We would all say that.
And it's he he he was very amiable the
way he talked about it. But of course if
we got a chance to do it again we would
do it better
and
however the number of people who ever
got a chance to do it again is zero.
So, it's a it's a very theoretical
discussion
and
but of course there's an old German
proverb I've always liked and it says
that man is too soon old and too late
smart. And that's true whether you're
Benjamin Franklin or Joe Klutz.
And we all live with that problem. And
and we're all pretty forgiving of
ourselves, too, which is probably a good
thing.
Charlie, uh, leave.
I wouldn't change I wouldn't change my I
wouldn't change my life all that well. I
think most people are
assuming tolerable success in life are
about as happy as they were ordained to
be. and they wouldn't be have been a lot
happier if they were richer or a lot
less happy if they'd been poorer. I
think most people have sort are born
with a happy stat and their happy stat
has more to do with their happiness than
their outcomes in life.
Um Lee would like to know u Mr. Mr.
Munger, your advice given on choosing a
good spouse in poor Charlie's almanac is
tur. You have said that the single best
way is to deserve a good to deserve a
good spouse. Uh because a good spouse is
by definition not nuts. That is true and
makes sense. However, could you be more
specific? You used examples of Lee
Kuanu's good judgment in choosing
someone with brains over certain
physical attributes in your past
interview. Could you give more examples,
both good and bad ones, from your
personal observations or through
vicarious readings?
Well, I can't top Lou's example in his
early education. He was the second
ranked
student in the school. He was that
smart. And there was one woman who was a
year older than he was who was the first
ranked student in the school. So, he
married her. And of course his son who's
a bright man is now what? Prime Minister
of Singapore.
A little wisdom in spouse selection is
very desirable.
You can hardly think of a decision that
matters more to human facility than whom
you felicity than who you marry.
Um
Chris uh from Park City, Utah would uh
like to know, Mr. Munger, given all of
your donations to physics, what is your
favorite way of applying physics to
society's problems and also to
investing?
I don't think I use much physics in
solving my investment problems, but it
occasionally helps me.
Occasionally some damn fool will will
suggest something that violates the laws
of physics and I always turn off my mind
the minute I realize the poor bastard
doesn't know any physics.
Uh Paul Ayani uh would like to know how
important is the analysis of company
culture in the investment process?
Well, it's quite important part of the
success of a company like Costco. And
it's been amazing that one little
company starting up not all that many
decades ago could become as big as
Costco did as fast as Costco did. And
part of the reason for that was
cultural. They they have created a
strong culture of of fanaticism about
cost and quality and so forth and
efficiency and honor all the good things
then and of course it's all worked and
so of course culture is very important.
Um, Charlie, uh, Jason Chin, uh, he
would like to know, uh, you often
advocate for learning from other
people's big calamities and stupidities.
Uh, what would be a mistake at the Daily
Journal where we can all learn from?
Well,
Jerry, what's the biggest mistake we've
made?
Well, we don't think about mistakes.
We take the situation as it is and try
to solve it.
I can't think of a
We paid high prices for some little
companies in the course of trying to
enter the court software business, but I
don't think that's going to end up a
mistake.
God knows it was difficult, but I don't
think it's a mistake.
I don't think we have made a lot of
horrible mistakes.
Look around these real estate. We bought
all these buildings cheaply. They're in
a place that's gotten more valuable
mostly. What's And I don't think it was
a mistake to buy the Daily Journal when
we did paying the price. We did. We paid
2.5 million for it. We got a dividend of
2 and a.5 million shortly thereafter.
Everything you see is profit.
I think we've coped pretty well so far.
U Freddy from Istanbul would like to
know, um, if you had a chance to make an
addition or revision to poor Charlie's
almanac, what would that be?
Well, I don't have any wonderful new
thoughts,
you know.
To the extent that my thoughts have
helped my life, I I think I've pretty
well run the course.
And uh I don't think I'm likely to have
any new thoughts that are going to work
miracles either.
And but I find that the old ways of
doing things still work. Uh I've been
engaged in recent years in trying to
create a better type of student
dormatory.
And I find that by working at that I can
actually make some improvements even
though I'm old.
So I'm I'm kind of pleased that I'm
still functioning at all. I'm I'm not
trying to move mountains.
Um a couple more questions left here. Um
we have one uh do you believe any
psychologically uh psychological
personality test such as the MyersBriggs
type indicator personality test to be of
any good in choosing a compatible
partner given that choosing a spouse is
probably the most important decision one
can make in life. Could you please
elaborate on the subject and could you
consider giving a talk on this
particular subject, the most important
decision in life to benefit those who
are single perhaps including some of
your grandchildren and
great-grandchildren?
Well, you know, I had a failed marriage,
so I don't think I'm a in a per perfect
position to advise the young about
marriage. And
no, I don't have anything to contribute.
Um, Charlie, uh, Victor Lou from Los
Angeles, uh, He would like to know what
have you done to live such a long life
and if you could share the secret to
living a long and healthy and happy
life.
Well, I think I'm alive because of a
lucky genetic accident.
And and I don't think I can teach you
how to retroactively get a new G
accident yourself.
And Jerry's lived a long time, too. And
I think we both been lucky.
No, I I I don't have any secrets
that
I think I would have lived a long time
if id lived a different life.
Any sort of wisdom though on you know
the what it takes to live a happy life?
What are those uh kind of principles?
Oh yes. Well well a happy life is very
simple. You you s you the first rule of
a happy life is low expectations.
That's one you can easily arrange. And
if you have unrealistic
expectations, you're going to be
miserable all your life. And so, and I
was good at having low expectations.
And and and that helped me. And
and also if when you get reverses, if
you just suck it in and cope, that helps
if you don't just
fretfully stew yourself into a lot of
misery.
And
then if there are certain behavioral
rules,
some of them, you know, Rose Blumin had
quite an effect on the Bergkshire
culture and she had such a she created a
business
with like 500 depression dollars that
became a huge business. You know what
her mottos were?
Always tell the truth and never lie to
anybody about anything.
And those are pretty good rules and
they're pretty simple. And a lot of the
good rules of life are like that.
They're just very simple. And do it
right the first time. Leequin, that
that's that's a really good rule.
I I suppose we have uh time for for one
more question. Um it's been a year since
the Corona virus pandemic came to the
US. Uh what have you all learned about
running a business in the past year? Has
there been anything that has surprised
you? And what would be your best advice
uh to someone starting a business now?
Well, I don't think I have a lot of
wonderful advice about starting a
business, but what we've learned in the
pandemic is that we can do with a lot
less travel
and a lot more zooming.
And I don't think that
when the pandemic is over, I don't think
we're going back to just the way things
were. I think we're going to do a lot
less travel and a lot more zooming and
and know I think the world is going to
be quite different.
A lot of the people who are doing this
remote
working that a lot of people are going
to work three days a week in the office
and two days a week at home. A lot of
things are going to change
and and I expect that and I I I I
welcome it.
Well, Charlie and Jerry, this has been
um such an excellent uh shareholder Q&A
and I know our viewers really appreciate
it. So, we only have a few minutes left
and it's hoping maybe for the both of
you if you want to just kind of share uh
some parting thoughts uh with the
viewers who are watching all around the
world.
Well, Jerry, what would we're really
old, both of us, and I I think both of
us have done the same thing. We just
suck it in and cope. We don't have any
other secrets, do we, Jerry?
None.
You have to be concerned about
employees lives. That's very very
important.
And for example, here we must have 30 or
40 desks.
And
we expect many of our employees to
always be at client court offices
because we work with them very closely
to make sure they get what they need.
And so
we do, as Charlie indicated, have a lot
of travel and that's been greatly
curtailed
and we can't go to many offices because
they're closed
and some of our technology
like eiling for example,
the courts are closed and
we are very excited to look forward
forward to enabling the courts to
function as we know that they want to
and will in the future.
So you have to be a little closer to the
employees needs and desires and and
babysitting and all those activities
that were kind of taken for granted in
the past. It doesn't happen anymore.
Everybody's got a different situation.
Nothing is particularly
uh obvious for everybody to do the same
thing. And we have to function as an
informal committee in that we have to
bring our employees and our clients
staff together to work out what they
already know and how we can help them do
a better job and a more efficient job.
So the people part is has changed quite
considerably. Being a small company,
we're beholdened to the guidelines of
the of the county of Los Angeles and
other counties. We have offices in all
the major cities in California and also
in Logan, Utah. And we are subject to
the orders and directions of those
counties which before really didn't
impact anything.
There's one thing that we're quite
passionate about and that is
serving the customers who have trusted
us
and
we are really interested in in
doing a good job in Australia and and in
California and in all the other places
where people have trusted us.
You can hardly think of anything more
important in life than being reliable
for the people who trust you. And we're
going to bust our ass to try and do a
good job. And
the Daily Journal shareholders will have
to take whatever outcome comes from
caring more about our customers than is
at all common.
Charlie Munger and Jerry Salsman, I
thank you so much for those nearly two
hours of your wisdom on business,
investing, and life. And I know our
viewers at home appreciate it. Be well
to you both. And more coming up on Yahoo
Finance Live after this.
[Music]